哇 台灣股市今天逆勢收紅
但是有三個問題
韓股正式破題
咪咪罵罵罵罵罵罵
台灣股市撐得住嗎
第二個問題
台幣一度大升1.8角
但是整個漲幅收斂
剛才收斂到0.6角
外資真的回流嗎
第三個
哇 AI的利空
哇 中國智炎晶片
真的是AI股的利空嗎
這三個問題今天是最關鍵的
我覺得這幾個月來
今天最重要
你今天不看我的节目
你真的会后悔
因为台湾股市好多问题等待
我来帮你解决
最近有消息指出
美伊的冲突又有扩大的迹象
加上中国的DeepSeek
为了降低对外部企业依赖
正自行开发AI晶片
很多同资朋友都很担心
这个利空消息是否会影响到台股
不过台股今天虽然早盘一度下跌
但投资涨的股票真的太强了
投资涨上周五早在节目上预告好戏登场的精彩
只要再一根就要全面喷出了
果然周一就抢先涨停创高
虽然昨天下跌
但今天一开盘马上就攻上涨停
把昨天没涨的全部都补回来
还有智源也一度喷涨停
想知道投资涨对于最新的盘式看法是什么
又会买进哪些标股吗
接下來就交給我們經濟日報選股冠軍
單季188%記錄保持者
同時也是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
最受歡迎的分析師
郭哲隆投資長
投資長好
李李 各位同盟大家好
你好你好
今天台灣股市真的很刺激
是
然後也很緊張
真的
最後收紅了
怎麼辦
可是我跟你講
我覺得我反而計劃
今天不要再去拉這尾盤
今天拉這尾盤
我覺得會跟國際股市越差越多
你知道嗎
是
真的是 你看一下這邊
今天是45734點對不對
對
你看是45564
逆價差乘幾何時已經170點了
很少見逆價差這麼大
是
其實還是有一群清醒的人覺得
台灣股市今天不應該拉尾盤
為什麼
我就說台灣股市不應該拉尾盤
我說今天而已
你不要緊張
因為你看到今天大盤漲0.56%
255點
0.56%
用%來說的話算還好
就是1%
我們都用1%來做標準
等於1%的一半嘛 對不對
好 所以算小漲
可是韓國股市跌5.35
我們就不得了了
5.35怎麼算你知道嗎
如果用4500點來算的話
大概就說2250點
一天跌2250點
多不多
多
而且這已經不是
這已經不是他第一次了
我們今天來討論韓國股市有沒有
是
今年六次熔斷
而且六次熔斷
而且很多次熔斷都在最近近期
這一週又出現過了
對
所以你看韓國股市這樣走勢
這不太對
韓國市這樣子
同學們你看一下
你們清醒一下
韓國市在跌下去
台灣的機體會影響
像你說去幹桿去
看一下這件事情
台灣唯一的好處是沒有兩倍
台灣有股票急握什麼的
我覺得是賭性堅強
是不是
這已經到這邊下去了
這邊不能跌破的
我昨天是說過記錄線型比這個不重要
這一條頸線不能跌破
它今天硬是跌破
這兩次這一條頸線
然後我們再畫一下
畫過去你比較有感覺
對
這一條頸線它是不能破的
對不起我有點歪
不是我人有歪
是我的線畫得有點歪
這條線是不能跌破的
它還跌破了
他不只跌破這條頸線
他還跌破另外一條生命線
大家都會看的
你不會看你這樣不行
就是季線
你看一件事情喔
這條是不是季線
沒錯吧
對
這條白色是季線喔
來
我們看一下季線
韓國股市
什麼時候有跌破季線
4月初
是不是
而且4月初的季線
他是很快就站上去喔
而且跌不深喔
是不是 沒錯吧
那你看現在不一樣啊
那時候4月初的時候
是戰爭的時候的印象中
有
那時候戰爭有沒有
哇 那時候只能喊到
就是說再跌個4000點
真的蠻準的
那時候想要34,000跌到3萬
34,000跌到3萬點
對不對 沒錯吧 對不對
還35,000跌到31,000
那時候你看到
剛好是奇長點
只能錯過了
因為本來是28,000
用力的買台灣50
這跟大家講來
所以慢慢的拉起來
從這邊慢慢拉起來
可是你看這一次有點乖離過高
應該這樣講
它已經正式破季線了
你明天沒有急速反彈是不對
他等於破兩個條線
一條就是我剛才說的這條頸線位置區
有沒有
第二條 季線位置區
來 我們再靠一次
頸線位置區
跌破 這邊條線有沒有
跌破了有沒有
有
等於前波的最低點
等於這邊全部太好了
這邊全部太好了
麥當勞 它是M型的
麥當勞是什麼意思
麥當勞 都斯維尼
慘了 現在沒有為大家
這條頸線也是有沒有
這條頸線嗎
有
也破了
兩條重要的關鍵線都破了
這不太對
所以台灣股市有點強弱之末
你說台灣股市可以走自己的路
原則上有機會
看起來有機會
因為我們最強的是台積電
我們最強的不是記憶體
應該說記憶體對我們的權重不大
是
所以你會看到說其實
今天台積電
今天台灣股市雖然一度
大跌多少點 我們看一下
我們最低45,034點對不對
我們一度大概大跌四五百點對不對
好
有沒有看到
雖然一度大跌四五百點
台積電有大跌過嗎
沒有啊
沒有耶
沒錯吧
一度大跌四五百點台積電沒跌
代表今天也是某種去槓桿
去中小型股的槓桿
那我很怕今天融資又增加啦
那現在當然有點冷靜
沒什麼不好
你有沒有發現到
為什麼我選的股票今天都能展
這就是我剛剛跟你講
現在選股很重要
你要嘛就選最基優的股票
台灣50或0050
你要就選什麼
我跟大家講
你要選低基期的股票
你看今天資源漲跌
我昨天說資源有什麼好跌的
他資源沒什麼好跌的
他就沒漲有什麼好跌的
你就選低的股票有什麼好跌的
我這樣一直講
有
我有選的股票就是沒什麼好跌的啊
今天有消息傳出來什麼
00982A是不是
也買微星
為什麼買微星
廢話嘛
你看看他想法都一樣啊
微星月線
之前月線跌到多少
還216元
從月線來看他是跌很深
從200元跌到100元有沒有看到
有
周線你看就知道跌很深啊
各位周線這樣跌
他這樣子打一個弧形底才乾噴出去而已啊
乾噴出去而已啊
所以你要找一個分心找底部的
找底部的
我這樣跟大家講啊 你現在為什麼要去拆
土長 到底那個國劇是漲還跌
怎麼最後給你殺下去
2492華興科
為什麼殺那麼兇
廢話之前殺那麼兇
是不是
是
他比
他比記憶體更沒有
更沒有那個
你知道像外資
搞得已經
因為一些頭顧分析師
你知道嗎
都會取口號
下個記憶體
就是被動元件
哇
這都是我們20年前的口號
你知道嗎
下一檔
國劇第二
國劇第三
他們也用我們這個講法
外資現在
你看
你告訴我
在我當分析師的時候
外資是外資
本土分析師是本土分析師
是
不知道是不是因為
現在越來越多人
看我們分析師的節目
越來越多看我的節目了
你知道現在
分析師跟外資的報告已經沒有什麼差別
這是International英文的差別而已
哇 很聳動喔 嚇一個記憶體
哇 被動元件 我要告訴你
你去問業內所有人
他會認同這一句話嗎
他會像被動元件擴產那麼困難嗎
被動元件會像記憶體擴產那麼困難嗎
被動元件的技術含量有像記憶體嗎
打 question mark
你懂不懂
被動元件有像記憶體
為什麼記憶體擴產那麼困難
因為機體以前是被壓著打啊
他不敢擴產啊
變動員機這幾年多少還是有賺錢啊
國際這幾年多少還是有賺錢啊
所以你變動員機長得那麼誇張
我就跟你講一件事情
你去看一件事
為什麼我之前有任有餘
我不敢說我現在所有會員賺錢
我前陣子之所以我會員都賺錢
沒有人達到
我認為我現在我所有的會員的報酬率
應該還是傲視尋雄
為什麼
因為我都選低七級的股票啊
沒有基本面基本上我不選
賺太多我基本上很不選
來問你一件事
為什麼
為什麼聯發科今天跌
你看又跌到4000元以下了
有沒有看到
有
你看我這4000多元的時候
先出清一半
然後最後全部出清是不是對的
是
是啊各位
聯發科出掉
國具出掉
你看4270元出掉
你看今天是
為什麼為什麼
聯發科現在弱勢
為什麼
我出掉國具弱勢
為什麼聯發科跟國具
我都那麼弱勢
因為我說過了
最好賺了一段已經走了
你要當股市渣男
有賺到
該賺到就要走
後面的青春連華
留給別人賺
沒有關係
你聽懂嗎
不用去債務這件事情
OK嗎
所以國具這件事情
有沒有看到
來
所以
要當股市渣男
你平常
你私底下要不要當渣男
我不管
最好不要當
可是
你在股市要當渣男
我講得很清楚啊
你看我股票
賣掉高基期的股票
選低基期的
這是為什麼我最近
績下傲視群雄
賣掉高基期的選低基期的
一堆股票今天還創新高
一堆人現在哀哀叫
一檔股票一次到頂
今天直接給你暫停板
扯不扯
這個大戶看起來
就是明天要給你拉暫停
這大戶我明天沒有拉暫停
我看不起他
站起來我會很狠
你有本事今天拉暫停
你明天就要拉了啦
看不見了 會激怒大戶
期待
激怒大戶 那你去吃個大戶
真的啦 我覺得那個大戶
如果今天硬拉的這大戶
明天沒有拉起暫停
我看不起他
這邊這麼有Guts敢拉暫停
明天就應該再拉了啦
聽懂嗎
這種走勢是明天應該再拉暫停啦
但我不敢說百分之百啦
好不好 衛船被他洗來洗去
這個精彩被他洗來洗去
我就覺得你今天就像這種拉法
你明天就應該拉暫停了啦
至少怎麼樣都要半更啦
我明天沒有5% 我覺得不及格 知不知道
這是我要跟大家講的
所以你去想想看 我找他分析師
好不好 來
先跟大家講
來 看今天直播人士
今天直播人士也差不多 總共7000多人嘛 對不對
犯半天假
我看一下 我看一下
目前看好是不是禮拜六比較容易犯假
小杏 你看啊
我覺得是禮拜六
是禮拜六齁 對吧
我們剛剛禮拜五晚上
那個半年的慶功宴一次
是
大物生氣明天跌停
不會我跟他同一個陣線幹嘛
幹嘛生氣
他沒有必要拿錢砸自己的腳
當然我也不要刺激人家
好不好
跌就補
沒錯你記得我的口號
我是買0050的股市專情來
這個0050叫專情
是不是知道
0050的專情不要亂買了
我是不是說過來
有沒有看一下
我現在剪一件事
981也算我覺得很好的
可是你看現在線圖
有沒有看到
線圖像是098100對不對
對
跟0050告訴我誰線圖比較好
0050啊明顯啊
我就說90%
就統計90%
只有主動型ETF的績效
還是會輸
我說國外是這樣子啊
主動型的ETF的績效
會輸市值型的ETF績效
而且我記得
市長你幫我查一下
我記得國外的報導好像是跟
是不是跟S&P500 ETF比啊
如果是跟納斯達克ETF比的話
那可能是95%以上市長你幫我查一下對不對 我忘記那時候我查你聽懂意思嗎這10幾年來納斯達克ETF是狂勝S&P500的ETF
那我說主動ETF
去國外的研究
主動型ETF
00981A有個A字
00982A
有個A字
這個主動型ETF的績效
90%是輸40型ETF
那這40型ETF
他們是跟S&P500
還是跟納斯達克
是要剛剛給我答案
不重點
反正他們就輸市值行
理論上就90%以後會輸0050
或甚至95%好不好
國外營就是這樣子
是
來來來 所以
算了 可是我跟你講一件事
因為投信常看我的節目
我不要啦 好不好
我不要公平他
沒關係 投信
我是小時候我覺得
我覺得主動型ETF的基金藝人
不是能幹的
因為他們壓力很大
是
他們薪水高
但是好像沒有分析師高
應該說沒有比很紅的分析師高
除非他們有業外收入
但是業務術他們不能做啦
好
你看事實上有講
他們輸的是標普500喔
所以我在解釋一次喔
國外的研究是90%的主動型ETF
會輸S&P 500的ETF
他如果是跟國外的主動型ETF
是跟40型ETF
是跟納斯達克ETF
我跟你講我看起來不是90%
我看是95%啦
是要比一下吧
你可以問一下AI為什麼的
你聽懂嗎
是
90喔 甚至95% 你聽懂嗎
因為這幾年的NAS標普500 ETF
是款輸納斯達克 ETF
那台灣是跟納斯達克 ETF
是跟那個S&P
是跟那個廢辦指數的 ETF
比較有關係 你聽懂嗎
聽懂吧 好不好
但是你也可以講
他們選的各股是也都科系股
沒關係啦
反正至少百分90好不好
結論是韓國股市不能再跌
好不好
那底也沒關係
你要選一些地基期的股票
我知道你還有錢
不要買零股
拉回去買點三五法則
其實我現在我的會員
大部分的會員都很開心
大部分
不能說百分之百
好不好
今天要拍桌子
不錯啊
三三七四
台電法說會下禮拜四請好不好
不要擔心好不好
你可以先擔心
今天這禮拜台風嗎
好不好
來來
那個投資長我們參加你會員
可不可以不要太推薦大家股票
因為我們有年紀人
你股票算錯
可不可以多推薦個兩三檔
不要重壓一檔好嗎
感恩有你
那個蕭茹
你應該不是
你是我會員嗎
他說知道的人
我其實我都注重風險
我跟你講
我明明有時候可以重壓一檔股票
收更多會員
收更多會費
可是基本上我
我應該
就我有印象起來
我應該沒有
尤其這幾年
我應該沒有叫一個會員只壓一檔股票
你們不用擔心
我所有會員都聽著
我應該沒有叫一個會員只壓一檔股票
就連簡訊我都寫得很清楚
基本上是五檔的起跳
五檔五檔太多也不好
就是以五檔為主
五檔所終
這樣講好像是沒有
這個跟政治傾向沒關係
五檔
然後股票
特別會員大概三檔
三檔到五檔
是
因為比較少有時候集中到兩檔
他沒有壓一檔了 好不好
沒有關係
這個會員朋友可能是
可能小小姐他說有年紀的
沒關係放大 有年紀的
沒有關係
你可能沒有看清楚
或沒有聽清楚
來
之前自動看指責都不用看股了
真的啊 我都跟你講重點的事情
投資產請教台積電看法
近期會繼續玩一下嗎
不會喔 看起來
外資應該知道很多消息
他有問
其實外資為什麼知道這些消息
外資有時候問台積電
他不一定會講
他是問台積電的上下游
他是問台今天上下有的
OK嗎
你看一下
無所謂則則推薦的股票
推薦的股票
沒有我們螢幕又暗了
請你解決這問題
我不能再看到第二次
前面有螢幕再暗了
沒有第三次
沒事沒事各位
不對應該是依依的事情
依依你要處理
無所謂則則推薦的股票根本不畏懼大盤
都是直接暴展
除了首算群連
有沒有看到 有人
我剛才扯遠了
我剛才自己螢幕的事情
跟各位沒關係
無所謂
這推薦股票根本不會去大盤
都是直接暴展
除了首算群連
好不好
資源賺很多
OK嗎
是
那就
有沒有看到
這會員見證喔
我這股票根本不會去大盤
有沒有看到
資源賺很多
有人說資源賺很多
資源我不敢說每一個人
成本一樣嘛
但是就是很
就是我的很多股票
都賺滿多你知道嗎
金彩也賺很多啊
你看我的股票還可以
今天還有兩根的股票展停板
是
環球金之前展停板
是不是 環球金看一下
我這是為環球金捏一板的耳汗
這個他到底多大力多啊
你知道嗎
他大戶裡面的大戶中施戶
完全不管會不會被管制耶
真的
他昨天又被處置了
昨天又被注意了啦
又被警示一次了啦
喔 今天警示不是要拉起來
為什麼今天不跌一下
我巴不得環球金今天跌你知道嗎
那你跟我講環球金殺 環球金殺不下去
你跟我講
我說我真的覺得你看喔
你不要到時候環球金
到時候
漲到2000塊
500元的時候
你看500元的環球金
我一直把他報到1000元
國際300元86 700元我走掉
我不後悔
因為我換到更強的環球金
我說過了
你選國去再攢一倍很難
可是你看到環球金現在目前為止
看起來是要再攢一倍
一倍又一倍
沒錯
我們是賺了幾根斬停板啊
各位
所以為什麼
其實很多會員現在很喜歡我啊
本來就喜歡我了
粉絲很多看我好幾年
都記得我一件事情耶
你知道嗎
姐姐我看你好久
從疫情的時候
哇 你那時候說一年內有解藥
我還不相信
你講話好臭屁喔
姐姐我很喜歡你耶
美菜一開始賺錢賺大錢了
第二次雖然美菜不准
但是你寧願自己賠錢
你也叫別人換掉
後來他讓我賺好多
好多人都看我很久的節目
很多人都看我很久的節目
有沒有
所以你要的就是這樣分析師
你看一件事我有股票四五百塊
然後這個股票很好玩的是
他每一天
這四五百塊
每一次回答他25%
那這麼巧合的
我認為很難有第四次了
真的嗎
我不敢講
說實話我不敢講
實在有第四次老天送給你禮物
每一次都回答25%
都下去回答25%
是不是
順利去相看等一下責任分析師
我不去吃貨
我不去馬歐炮啦好不好
這6488的環球金啊
我預告在前面啦
真的賺很多
你自己看一下
你看一下
看我臭屁一下好不好
看一下看一下
來我們數一下暫停板好不好
環球金還賺到124%
之前任值150啦
是
我很貪心 我想要賺更多
但南亞科不能再跌
我覺得南亞科有一個重要關鍵點位
那我們看
環球金
精彩等一下再說
精彩剛才剛講而已
環球資源
你看一堆股票
環球金暫停
暫停
三個四個
五個
六個七個
八個九個
你看一下
我那時候還
跌停版喔
還在730元買
厲不厲害
730元買的都差不多賺100%啦
是
都快賺100%啦
所以我再次加碼股票還能再賺100%
對不對
我再次加碼股票還能將近賺100%
再將近翻一倍
730元
講兩次
所以我現在很多股票
你知道我很困擾
我還巴不得一些股票跌多一點
像世界先進最近跌
該買就買啊
莫名其妙
基本面沒差
你就環球晶展
世界先進不會跌嗎
除非就是純粹是善有漲
環球晶會展是因為
世界監禁
這些
怎麼樣
這些金圓代工有需求嘛
跟散油的環球金要嘛
是
要細金圓嘛
就這麼簡單嘛
所以除了會員金掛鐵艇
730元買金
會員掛鐵艇
已經持有環球金老會員
也可以加碼
我還叫你加碼
所以基本上
剛才有說
剛才有一個是老會員
或是年紀比較大的
對
我這邊很多年紀大
你不用擔心
我動作不會很快
你問所有會員知道
我動動到很快
沒有
待就補 跌就補
我不敢說每一檔股票都不追高
但我已經很少追高了
我已經很少追高了
環環晶最經典的
跌停板才追嘛
第一人能買嘛
你看十幾個
十二個展停板
十四個展停板
很累你知道
二 四 六 七
十五個展停板
我们念一下好不好
好
7月6号星期一
恭喜6488环球晶
一出關就直接喷展停
再創歷史新高
我们买进到现在最高
已经获利150%
我持续看好它
手上持股获利续报
恭喜大家赚大钱啦
好 恭喜大家赚大钱
我们手上持获利续报
没闷到
这还成金150%
这是礼拜一的
我讲在前面
我不是跟钱老师不一样
你知道吗
好不好
来 我们看一下
细节还在涨
既警告一次做兩次要關
首長請教中東局勢
等一下會跟你講好不好
立體除了
好吧
來
新參加的會員可以買環球機嗎
可以買環球機
你好問題耶
你那個
因為你們
會員的有好處是
你有時候我要賺你的成本
如果你有這問題的話
你問我們那個助理說
請你
請你轉達給這次之後說
好不好
請我們助理這樣
新參加會員買環球機
我不知道你的成本你知道嗎
如果是簡訊會員
基本上就按照我買的點去買
沒有關係
我會破例一兩次沒有關係
大家可以
我會幫你做一個資產規劃
我幫你做一個資產規劃
大部分這次所謂比較高階的會員
會整個全身的資產規劃
是
你聽懂嗎
好不好
顯照者的螢幕變暗會如何
沒有就前面我的螢幕我看不到
沒事
合金應該要關了
不眼的直接閃電了
字眼一定會噴 謝謝
謝謝
頭長不要生氣
字眼有沒有機會跟上團角金腳步
我覺得是
昨天有人問財政科嘛
財政科這個有機會
或者是5483中美金有機會
有沒有問到
細菌園這一塊
為什麼細菌園這一塊
沒在展
你們繼續記得之前
你看這就是我覺得
這就是什麼
人棄我
人取我餘
我當然要記slogan
你看我都講一件渣男語錄
股市就像
你要當股市渣男
賺到錢就要落跑
渣男語錄二
人欺我取
不是人欺你要取
會出事
人欺我取
人取我語
是不是
星星你看
我還記得星星
去年的時候被人家念
還有人被人家慫恿
說什麼字就會
我快氣死了
很多人說快笑死了
因為你要是相信那些人
慫恿你 同樣慫恿你
我跟你講
你欣欣出了70元
今天在跌那麼慘還是有863元
從70元轉到1130元
你聽懂嗎
懂
可是人家不要的時候
人家不要人氣的時候
人家人氣的時候我就買它
你聽懂嗎
欣欣我們看一下
你看
從120、130
得到70塊
我被人家罵死了你知道嗎
是
我被人家罵死了
結果是那些慫恿我的那些救揮員們
害死他們了
因為他們慫恿那些人以後
是不是他們就一定不相信我
就會賣股票
基本上當會員賣掉我手邊的股票的時候他也不會相信我你明白嗎是後就這樣股票 70塊一路長 長多少你沒有看錯 長到1100元
過過了
人欺我取
是人欺我取
哭哭對不對
真的會哭哭
你剛才說什麼 哭哭嗎
錯過了
錯過了 也會哭哭
也是哭哭
對啊
70塊跟863塊差很多
你看現在要破底 還在86
所以股票是跌的你要開心
你知道嗎
股票跌要開心
我們要平產心
要開心
好不好
你看你看你看
你看世耀幫我做的
放大
你看我的直覺多準
在15年的長期投資中
大概有95%以上的主動型ETF有沒有
蘇納斯達克100ETF
請教我天才
我直覺太強了
真的很強
我剛才是臨時問世耀的
我還叫世耀去跑個資料
跑個AI或跑個
是
所以我跟人家說 AI做這種研究文獻是很厲害的
因為我後來發現不對 我抱抱抱
好像有那個
好像有百分之那個
好像就是我抱抱我記得有90%是跟標普500比
我想說我心一恆 心一改變
不對啊 我們台灣的組裝型ETF要跟台灣50比
台灣50是比較偏電子股的啊
是
所以我應該跟組裝型ETF應該跟
不要跟標普500的EPF比
應該是跟納斯達克的ETF
因為納斯達克的ETF比較像台灣的電子股
是不是
真的耶
而且他就講喔
95%以上都會輸喔
準不準
知覺很強吧
所以主動型ETF
輸更長喔
不是90喔
很多玩紅人有學我
現在90%
我不要講誰啦
只95喔
如果台灣50%可能輸更長
先跟你講邏輯喔
所以你一定要買嗎
可是我再講下去
人家沒有
主動型ETF的經營人
你們也不要生氣
我不是拆你們牌
就好再怎麼講
還是有人會買你們的
好不好
你們拼好你們績笑就好了
我也不想得罪你們
祝你們賺錢好不好
都愛你們
只有講話很實在
你不要這樣
哲哲現在都不為錢
不為錢去影響
是
我其實有一些會員
哲哲你怎麼叫我不要融資
我要借錢來參加你的會員
My man
拜託
你不要這樣參加我會員
不要勉強
好不好
歡喜做甘願壽
你看我現在反而也沒有憂慮
為什麼
因為我過年真金白銀在買
不要去借這個錢
我會說他有泡泡沫化
泡沫化跌很凶
但我跟你講
台灣股市來說會上5萬點
他會上6萬點 上7萬點
他到最後整個泡沫化才下去
他所謂泡沫化是AI會存在
AI運用會存在
很多人一直說
現在AI沒有新的程式
你們講的都是看到現在
我看的是未來
因為我越來越用AI
我發現他真的有思考的能力
我應該是我身邊我所有的人
我遇到最後問題的人
我這樣講跟你講好了
我講一個東西
我臨時講一個東西
就好像
這好像人家私事
沒關係
某個朋友
比如說得了一個癌症
那得了癌症以後
那你要看它會不會復發嘛
是
是不是
然後是重粒子
然後用重粒子
像我用重粒子
像很多人不一樣的
像癌症很厲害
有各種不一樣的
或者用免疫系統
把它
把它攻擊回去
或怎麼樣的
這個醫學我不太強
但是你只要會問問題
比如說我這個癌症這三期
我又幫他問問題
這三期的癌症
然後用重粒子以後
好像就是沒有再復發了
然後怎麼樣的情況
然後這邊的癌症怎麼樣
彎晶是怎麼癌的
是
某種
你其實你問完醫生後
有些醫生不一定很專業
我不是在罵醫生
就像最近不是有個法官嗎
他之前有在中校新生上出了車禍
有沒有一個好像大的卡車
拖車 鑽石一個護理師
媽媽很生氣啊
媽媽很生氣是說
然後那個卡車司機的話就死掉了
就告業者
然後法官不就是說
就說一句話嗎
說你有很難過嗎
講那什麼話
聽了生氣
對啊 我的意思是說法官跟醫生一樣
大部分法官跟醫生人都很好
但是少數的人他是沒有同情性的
可是你有AI的時候
你可以做輔助
當醫生判斷錯誤的時候
你只要問清楚AI
他會告訴你很多答案
我跟你講那只是某種應用
我只告訴你AI他有很多判斷能力
真的很好用
我一天至少要問他個50題問題
我都不誇張
50題太扯太扯
20題真的以上有
有時候有會再問啦
你知道嗎
20題每天都問
因為我是天馬行空
比如說問到為什麼
比如說你每天有很奇怪
我看月飛的故事
我想為什麼他會被人家
那個
被人家咔嚓掉
廢話啊
原本的皇帝已經被他
被他爐到北部去了
你還叫現在的皇帝說
要把原本的皇帝送回來
那現在皇帝不把你咔嚓掉
那誰
那還跟你說
還謝謝你
你聽懂意思嗎
懂
岳飛為什麼會被人家
你看12道金牌
廢話
你的目的就是要
要把原本的皇帝送回來
那現在皇帝怎麼辦
是
不懂做人的厚道啊
很多人只說哇
勤快這壞蛋
不是 我用後悔醫學
來去了解這些事情
那你會用AI嗎
你懂得懂 好很好
這很多事情
所以這醫學歷史
比如說那個
醫生有時候不會跟你講那麼多
因為他怕有法律糾紛
你知道嗎
像醫生是這樣子
很怕在電話中跟你講很多
可是你可以問他說
比如說我這個癌症
假設我癌症
這個癌症
你五年的付存活率是多少
是
有時候醫生不一定敢講那麼清楚
可是你只要給他購多資訊
AI會講得很清楚
不懂嗎
你問兩個AI
說我兩個AI都會問
兩個AI都會問說
比如說你五年的存活率有90%
基本上你就應該開心了
前提是你問問題方式要對
數據要對
真的很好用啊
很多人說現在沒有一個共通程式
對啦 你們就是一個沒有獲利模式
可是你少看了
AI真的有自主性思考的時候
Enthopic說最近的一個有自主思考
就像人的腦袋一樣
突然爆發出什麼想法
他也不能跟你解釋
是
你們看的是現在
我看是現在進行那麼快
未來的發展會很恐怖
你懂嗎
機會是留給準備好的人
你記得我特斯拉
最後一台特斯拉
全台灣最後一台
X
特斯拉 X
的車子
我買的
我到現在也沒有開
我就等台灣的政府
通過IFSD
我好好的去感受它
那你知道什麼叫AI
我就是這樣子
我做的事情就是機會留給準備好的人
買台車也要好幾百萬
而且買很貴的
加一加四百萬吧
反正最貴的車子
所以它可以聽賞
我就純粹為了自駕而已
這就是你們花錢找我的原因
我就是為了研究AI
所以你們花幾萬塊
結果我有幾百萬的一個研究資訊
你懂嗎
可能很多網紅到時候跟你講FSD自駕
可能上片的時間會跟我一樣
或更快
可是問題是
第一個我上片的時間也不會太慢
第二個我是真實的享受
第三個我純粹為了研究
我會更了解股票
你懂嗎
機會永遠只留給準備好的人
好不好
他們講那些東西我都知道
都知道 可是好不好
OK 這跟大家講
所以他們講這些我都知道
可是你要找一些真正了解
股市基本面的好不好
夜盤不要崩啊 明天要拖累資源競載
我剛好夜盤有崩嗎
我剛好跟你講今天台灣股市不該
不該漲那麼多
說老實話 明天跌一點也好
其實韓國股市不能再跌
我跟你的結論是韓國股市不能再跌
因為雖然它
我們台灣是漲台積電
不會被人家抵制啊
你知道嗎
他們三家
有人說三家壟斷啦
海力士 美觀 三星
台灣就台積電
比較不會被人家抵制啊
清晶智成比較不會被抵制
而且台積電漲價比較厚道一點
可是這都是AI的題材
韓國現在去幹桿也沒什麼不好
兩種情況嘛
什麼兩種情況
來
一種情況是韓國股市對不對
直接拉上去嘛對不對
對
去看看
喔
被TF死的死
王的王
大家不敢亂買了
OK 拉起來
另外一種情況就是
哇 台灣股市跟韓股市一起下去
這不是廢話嗎
就這兩種情況
對 這是廢話
可是我可以確定的是
韓國股市在破下去
台灣股市很難怎麼樣
置身於世外
聽懂嗎
是
很難置身於世外
記得我講這東西好不好
就講這東西
所以你去想看
你要長的分析師好不好
我不去吃後外
我不去買厚厚炮
我就是預告在前面
自從跟著哲哲以後
展翼都平常心
真開心的無聊
對啊
就是很開心的無聊
悠哉
對不對
好學生太乖了
開除他換中美金和微星
你看我股票很低機器
是不是
哲哲
我最近有檢查肺結結
切片檢查
不是很好
是不好的需要手術
醫生講得很輕鬆
但我問AI
答案很詳盡
放大放大
問AI答案很詳盡
但我檢查好像有多憂慮
對啊對啊
本來就是AI會很多
AI會很多告訴你答案的
好不好
可是你問清楚的時候
你也不要引導他
不要引導式
就是很中立的問他
因為引導式的答案
他會說是不是這樣就不好
他一定會
他會道歉
對 這樣只是不好
他會跟你道歉你知道嗎
所以有些小女生就喜歡
跟他聊天
培養
提供他情緒價值
例如我們的依依
還是像每天跟他聊天嗎
比較少
比較少了
對
唉
那個
有了新歡就忘了舊愛是不是
沒有
為什麼比較少
就煩惱沒那麼多
煩惱沒那麼多
好來煩惱沒那麼多
那最好
美觀跟海力士要跌破了好不好
哲哲特斯X加FSD要400萬
哲哲就是願意多花400萬研究AI
真的我是為了研究他而已
對啊
韓國股市不要鬧
真的不要鬧
就像這個我也沒有差
我覺得大家都平常心
就像我講的
我沒有去很在乎所謂的一些
人家就是我之前
人家亂搞我
搞一些违犯的費用
律師費我都沒有在乎
因為我覺得
我說老實話啦
或者我覺得特斯拉這些錢
都是一環嘛
沒辦法
當第一名就這樣子
那我覺得很多人
與其攻擊我
不如大家
我不能說粉絲
粉絲不會攻擊我
我說有些同業
我覺得不如大家來比賽
績效第一以外
比大家誰捐的錢比較多
好不好
桃園市政府
有沒有看到
我們捐救護車一台
年底就可以拿到了
我已經連續兩年捐救護車了
我希望這一輩子捐個22台
捐個3億元以上
我是認真的
好不好
我覺得認真
讓這個社會更好
不要只是攻擊人家
好不好
我覺得這樣子
這只得沒錯吧
捐救護車一台
年底拿到
那個韓文
記給我
資源過225以後
是不是有機會挑戰25元
來 我們來看一下資源
225以後
没有错
你这个基础升级学的不错
225以后
就会挑战245
但我觉得不一定
但是我可以确定
如果他可以
可是我觉得他会很快突破245
你不要看那么短
225在这边你知道吗
你不要看那么短你知道吗
245在这边
我是可以告诉你突破245的话
很快300元
我的想法是这样子
很快突破300元
是
好不好
但是有些股票
有时候不是不一定
比如说我红海
我也不能说每次都赚
你说红海你看
他最近就不行
是不是
對不對
對紅海這邊除泉洗
所以沒有回答那麼深
按還原就知道有沒有
紅海之前這樣跌對不對
我覺得跌的莫名其妙
其實我也是認為紅海是有機會試來用
我是認真講
所以你這邊股票拉回你就買
你知道我很困擾
我現在很困擾是
我要買紅海
還是買世界先進
你知道嗎
我最近今天後來拉尾盤
是不是
我講了嗎
你看今天跌下去
我們跌快25%
今天168嘛
我們看一下喔
我們用223除16
168除223
不對不對
因為它有4.4元
好啦沒關係啦
223除以5嘛
223-5好了等一下喔然後除以168嗎反過來168除以218好了
沒關係
它會回檔23%
好不好
是
23%0.77
1-0.77等於23%
所以我覺得股票回檔20%差不多了
好不好
只能明天穿粉紅色就噴了
我再跟你講
我要跟你講
台灣股市真的很強
但我不希望台灣國是一支獨秀
好不好
我不希望台灣國是一支獨秀
宏海斯是非文關係
我不要去理人家的事情啦
他已經退休了
對啊
好不好
如果他今天董事長就聊了
肝胺酸美一開始吃真的有效
吃久了有時效果變差
對 我之前推薦肝胺酸美
我吃肝胺酸美是有效
但是有時候怎麼樣
重點還是你內心
要平靜
有沒有看到
然後第二個
吃肝胺酸美
聽說現在開始流行吃肝胺酸美
好像我帶動的
剛剛說他沒有缺點吃太多
有時候會拉肚子
所以你要注意一下
你是不是因為吃這個關係
哲哲好帥喔
謝謝你
有賺錢就帥
沒賺錢就醜
良性競爭很好
對啊
同業良性競爭比較好
不要隔空講那些有沒有的
記得一件事
不要嘴巴說績效很好
那要攻擊別人
績效很好的人
不需要攻擊別人
是
為什麼沒錯
因為每個股票展停板
會有會員會
會收會員能數會差嗎
昨天這我問過你的問題
對
不會
莉莉 我再請問你一件事
是
如果某個人績效很好
他有可能收不到會員嗎
不會啊 不可能
怎麼可能
所以不要一直說自己績效很好
然後然後
然後收不到會員
那績效很好
那問你績效很好
你會去攻擊人家嗎
不會
沒有時間啊
你每天要斬停板
哪有時間攻擊人家
那攻擊別人
基本上績效都不太好
這是很簡單的邏輯
不用欺騙了
不用欺騙自己
好 我們不要扯遠了 我們不要扯遠
我們不要扯遠
有網友講說不要每天扯這些
我也覺得是
好 來
來 我們今天外資賣超379億
所以我們看一下
所以有很多股票是這樣子
我們先休息一下好不好
要休息嘛
休息一下好不好
只得喝個水
因為我不要扯遠
我趕快把一些股票講一下
我剛才還是有講一些股票
我們講就是說台灣股市該怎麼漲
對對對 南亞科
記憶體怎麼看好不好
南亞科的記憶體還有台積電怎麼看
我們休息一下 忙回來
投資長 對於群聯還有南亞科
您的看法是什麼呢
來 我們來看一下
那阿科
240半那阿科
我有說過
這看起來好像很強
那我覺得
我怕主力是邊拉邊出
你看他故意開高
有沒有可能邊拉邊出
注意一下
因為你這邊頸線
你是一樣不能破
那有沒有可能主力往我
頸線破又拉起來
那不重要
其實我跟你講一件事
有時候你
因為我跟你講
有時候你不要去預設
那麼多預設
畢竟我的成本低
是
我們成本在一兩百塊左右
成本低
你不要想那麼多
我成本硬要說
我從50幾塊一路買上來
50幾塊
所以我覺得
但是很多
你說很多大戶
主力忠實會不會看我節目
一定會啊
投資廟
你去看一件事
哪個分析是有100萬粉絲
我是134萬粉絲
比很多電視台還多
對
134萬訂閱者
你去比較一下
好不好
然後最好笑的是
平常點閱率算不錯
但是只有大跌的時候
點閱率更好
昨天點閱率一下子
就增加好幾萬人了
真的
真的好不好
OK啊
這個呢
好 來來來
來來來
所以我要講說
納科不能再破底
再破底
該走 我們就該走
好不好
我的想法是這樣子
那整個正式的價格一定是
以我的會員潛信
以我的操作指令為主
OK嗎
好
那我們來看一下
那還有股票
這知道樊軒怎麼看
我覺得金財會這樣展
樊軒不會太差
你不覺得金財跟樊軒
有時候有點異不異區嗎
金財沒辦法拉起來
我覺得樊軒
但是你不能說他們兩個
一致性一樣
做的東西不一樣
只能說勉強歸類
都是台積電資本支出概念股
只是金財拉起來的情況之下
你會覺得說
台積電的產能
還是很蠻窄
很天的嗎
所以金財會拉
樊軒我覺得都有機會的拉
台積電資本支出概念股都拉
只能怎麼看
你不能這樣講
樊軒這一階段根本沒跌
今天正式跌比較凶一點點
可是尾盤硬要拉起來
好不好
我的股票真的很強
你這樣看
樊軒你看
它根本就沒有落實
你看到
我大部分股票
你看到哪個
哪這麼明顯
看到國具這麼明顯的錯頭
是不是
很多人的股票
你看3037星星
因為這都是我不要的股票了
我已經當股市渣男了
M頭
你知道嗎
不是罵大家M頭
是M頭
M頭是傻瓜
應該是
所以很多股票這樣子
賣太多的追
剛好人說好學生不要
技嘉
我那時候有跟大家講
我說技嘉跟
我那時候有講
大家想起來了沒
沒想起來沒關係
我跟妳講
我們看一下喔
我們技嘉
技嘉是這樣展對不對
然後微星是在這邊
有沒有
對
微星在這邊
你們不相信我們看一下喔
是不是
沒錯吧
沒錯
再看一下喔
是不是
位階就不一樣嘛
一個在這邊
一個在
這邊
你要選強勢股啊
然後強勢股回檔的時候買啊
維新我覺得這樣還有機會買喔
為什麼你0982要買
選低基金股票哪會錯啊
一堆股票六七萬點
要不然四五萬點要不然六七萬點
我選個兩萬多點股票怎麼會差啊
本益比很多按鈕我要選那個台達店
你瘋了選台達店
台灣股市在哪一天崩盤呢
台達店嘴嘴嘴嘴嘴嘴我跟妳講
又是被本益比
不要開玩笑啦
一邊這邊增加多少
又是被本益比
很多說台灣股市的本益比很低
你為什麼不看電子股
有些的股票本益比
但你不能看平均嘛
台灣為什麼台灣股市本益比很低
你知道嗎
被那些傳產股的本益比壓低了
傳產股根本沒在漲啊
如果用電子股本益比
台灣的股票有些本益比很高
尤其用單一的個股來看的話
本益比有夠高的
好不好
所以那個遲到修正
修正就這種台雅電這種
本益比很高的股票你知道嗎
基本上我覺得我都不建議你碰超過40倍 50倍
除非是說剛開始轉正
虧轉贏的話本益比會很高
在你時候虧轉贏
因為你有時候你還從賠錢變0.5元1PS
變1元1PS
可是不好意思它可能漲到100元為什麼
因為你知道什麼嗎
因為它預期的是之後可能賺個3元4元
虧轉正的本益比本來就很高了
記著這句話
可是如果你的1PS是慢慢增加的
那這種本益比你不應該5 60倍
記得我這些邏輯
其實就是這個邏輯
其實沒有很少分析是像我這樣子
我記憶體我昨天講一個最經典的話
很多人說暗戰
我說記憶體怎麼樣
現在開始之前看基本面
對
現在你不要看基本面
我問你啦
我問你一件事啦
你在跟你看三星走勢啊
四條哥三星走勢
三星跟海力士的走勢
基本面有變差嗎
沒有
不要跟我開玩笑
那個達標
昨天公布我才有達標
為什麼你鬼在走
因為技術線型走在前面
現在技術線型
尤其記憶體的技術線型
讀论多人按讚啊 喜欢这句话
现在记忆体的记数现行
现在记忆体的记数现行怎么样
这个简介不能破
现在记忆体的记数现行比基本面很重要
因为2022年 2021年 2022年
的什么
2021年 2022年的残农扬名
股价先从一开始的什么
2020年 2021年
先从股价从20块 10块不到
涨到200多块
再從200多塊跌到100塊以下的時候
這個過程 跌的過程中怎麼樣
不好意思
營收一直創新高
你看基本面有什麼用
我害死你啊
要看技術陷阱
所以你看我講這個話就是一樣
這個時候技術陷阱比基本面重要
我講什麼話我都非常的
告訴大家的邏輯
什麼台積電資本支出
都是我第一時間跟大家講
然後微信也是這樣
散物在想什麼
大戶在想什麼
主動型ETF在想什麼
主動型ETF的經濟人在想什麼
幫我們抬轎
沒關係
因為我選的股票
本來就是很好的股票
你知道嗎
很好的股票
先跟大家講
投資長
你說
我覺得您講得很對
在現在這個震盪的時期
要唱歌對不對
要更相信投資長
來不及了吧
像幾分了
47分
可以
47分沒關係
等明天再唱了好不好
明天嗎
明天明天
好
明天明天好不好
那我把它結束完
不然一一要變酷酷了
好不好
很想唱是不是
好
我很喜歡看紙的分析股票
什麼都聊
也很幽默
謝謝大家
好不好
日本股市看起來現行超級不樂觀
不要看日股
看韓股就好
韓股的現行比日股還差
OK嗎
請問群年什麼時候噴出
夜盤期會翻紅的
我還是跟大家講
你韓國股市不能一直跌
好不好
接著說5097年還OK
可能股票今天太強了
好不好
反現本一比還OK
跟其他的那個
台積電資本支出概念股
還好
看一下群聯嘛
群聯還不錯啦
可是我跟你講
如果南亞科疊群聯
也會變自身失歪一點點
這我最怕的
好不好
所以我還是
為紫祈禱文
我還是
為群聯祈禱文
好不好
這跟大家講
希望一下好不好
來來
選台達電部
選群聯
這兩個東西不太一樣
只在教邏輯
沒有錯
來
來來
他說很多人可能參加會議後沒有看節目
只有大碟才會來看節目怎麼辦
好啦 所以我們最後要跟大家講
你看喔 我們今天的股票看起來很爛
台灣股市看起來股票很爛
對不對
精彩漲停
沒錯吧
沒錯
精彩漲停
就是你剛才說群聯
其實群聯喔
今天也是小碟而已耶
跟南亞科差很多有沒有
是不是
為什麼 因為南亞科都是南亞科在漲啦
群聯 所以為什麼
選那種漲不多的股票
有時候是你的護身符
你看到今天
我們的金彩
你不要看金彩現在漲很多
金彩前陣子根本還在3萬點的金彩
所以金彩你看一路漲
是不是還有誰
5483中美金也一路漲啊
是
沒錯吧
所以還在低基期
股票沒有到
不能說他一直漲的股票
之前有到234元有沒有到
所以現在208元還好
低基期的中美金
低基期的金彩
還在漲停的精彩
還有誰
好多股票
6488環球晶
漲不停啊
賺了150%
還有3035智元
天啊
一堆股票都在漲停
你去想看你要漲分析師好不好
想清楚了
想明白了
Y奶店恰群
0800668085
全台灣唯一100萬
110萬以上粉絲的分析師
全台灣唯一位
這大家都可以見證
可以查閱的事情
也是經濟日報
有史以來最高的銜股
基於保持者
就是在下
不好意思
所以歡迎來你叫錢
08068085
或加我哪裡試試我
我準備下一檔標股了
其實現在也很多標股可以買
不論對貨錯
整整一切一切
預告前面
去想看你要展分明師
記住我們之前大貨全勝
就是在環球星
跌停板的時候
一直叫人家買
你想要不要再複製
這樣的行情
想的話
趕快加入行列
也預祝各位能夠賺大錢
謝謝各位
拜拜
本公司与所推介分析之个别有价证券
无不当之财务利益关系
本节目资料仅供参考
投资人应独立判断
审慎评估并自负投资风险
谢谢大家